hello who are you i am tony goldmark aka
some jerk with a camera
hey moseying into my job I'm auditioning
to be his new brother I didn't want to
tell I'm the only jerk here let's get
that straight well and the camera does
find being a jerk - it's a jerky camera
yeah but now we are going to talk about
a haunted mansion good we're all Sienna
we've all talked about it and it's good
that you're here because like I don't
remember Lee remember that all I
remember things about this movie you
hear me a black hole in my head you
probably remember like much more about
it because I mean you specialize like in
theme park right yeah like that dizzy in
general but my first few things we can
talk take it away we're going to go just
grab coffee and lettuce well you know
it's interesting because for years you
know the park had been open for like 40
or 50 years and they had never turned
any of their rides into movies virus was
the first law no no the country bears
was the first one any pop Johnny
IRA also say was that the first yes I
mean plantation England was the first
one based on a ride but yeah the first
one based on an attraction was the
country bears and it's interesting
within like a year and a half after
never after never making any movies
based on park attractions they made
three they made the country bears the
first Pirates movie and the Haunted
Mansion within a year and a half of each
other so it's like this binge of you
know let's just adapt all these you know
I'm chairs I have a question
go on out of all of these why would you
do the country bears first what what
made them look at that right and say you
know what movie you know honestly I've
been thinking about this for a while
because a lot of it a great attraction
is but it's not without its charm I
suppose well what's really puzzling
about the country bears is that
literally I'm not making this up they
closed the ride in Disney or of the
attraction in Disneyland like eight
months before the movie came out like as
I was saying it was not a what after
what what I love about I definitely have
a bear finish
I was going to say because I haven't
seen the country bears I skipped it but
my wife really wanted to see the Ricky
ticky tacky room and like yeah we wanted
a tiki yeah oh yeah Ricky picketing here
uh you know birthing so and when I went
there like it was about dollars as
always but like when they sing like I
couldn't even hear the singing of the
voices over the yeah being going all you
hear is like yeah kinky Peggy tell you
there's like the other engineer's worked
hard I have done other survey cannot be
Enchanted Tiki Room is the birds are
right like over you so they're a lot
closer what the country beers actually
those are kind of far away on a stage so
you don't hear that stuff as much but
the shows how good haunted mansion movie
is see how we have even really talked
about yeah I just have other attractions
10-minute talk about the Pirates of
Caribbean movies I like that movie I
know everyone's really good it's
interesting of the three movies the
pirates was the one that Michael Eisner
wanted to make the least because it was
the most expensive like he almost shut
it down right behind is there was behind
now oh yeah this is the obvious are
bullish in the decisions they ice okay
this is the tail and you a tiger why was
pentagram is Michael ice beer do you
want to put more money and move on - Oh
big Lee specifically I think my theory
is Eisner was tired of trying to buy the
Muppets enough like let's just make our
own Muppet Adam eyes bears I
don't I just realized something
I just got a bear fetish thing man
because no like the first the first
movie wants me out of traction country
bears what was the first animated thing
he wanted to do on TV call me baby bears
man because on when because his son
loved the gummy bears candy it's like I
think I oh I'm a good son wasn't a coke
addict my baby home bouncing here and
everywhere um yeah I forgot his start in
Saturday morning he was like the head of
ABC's Saturday morning division so when
he came to Disney Disney it always
resisted Saturday morning because like
now the animations to achieve we wanted
to be up to this level of quality
and eiszner just said guys there's way
too much money to be made in this we're
going into animation so he started up
this whole division starting up this
whole division and the first memo he
sent to them was like hey my son really
likes those gummy bear candies could you
make a show about that just a jerk oh my
god I did is equated Eisner to like
General Patton where it's like yeah he
did that battle thought he was great in
that moment and the master is like okay
now we're established now we're going to
put oh this guy's actually crazy
yeah that's a really good and I'm
working longer I'd like just like I give
him credit for doing what he'd be done
there but at some point it was clear
there's like none of the same working
anyway he made Disney such a victim of
its own success at that one yeah
absolutely just talking about this now
and we still got into the Haunted man
I've got a right how we got got the hata
man trying to keep this going as long as
possible
my favorite song about this move okay
here's how here's why I think the
Haunted Mansion movie was made with
Eddie Murphy now like I said back in the
80s before he was with Disney he was the
head of paramount and paramount famously
was the last studio to ever to do an
actor exclusive thing where a certain
actor could only make movies for this
one studio that actor was Eddie Murphy
huh in the 80s Eddie Murphy was only
allowed to make paramount movies because
they basically tricked him into signing
one of the last of those kinds of
contracts and that's why he couldn't do
Ghostbusters he's a guy who easily
tricked yeah especially back then when
he was just kind of this know-nothing
kid who got huge on you know SNL and
stand up Ernie hooks would mean well a
steady paycheck involved no no no there
you go but yeah that Winston was written
for Eddie Murphy yeah but they couldn't
but because it was a Columbia picture he
couldn't do it now this was some ways to
do ghosts yeah that do something
pretty much and now Eisner is relishing
the opportunity to catch Eddie Murphy in
a ghost movie
I honestly think just the irony of that
was too delicious for Eisner doors in
its money no I gotta miss Farquaad from
Shrek yeah coming at you yes ma'am
that's a fascinating theory Oh clearly
didn't make a good movie ah you know and
just
more on things like you know yeah the
Haunted Mansion movie let's make this
about the guy who's a liar
I mean who get this we want to know
the guns we want to fun with the gospel
I think like what little I remember of
the movie and it's very well I'm not
joking I really is like this black hole
in my brain like I still forgot about it
almost instantly I just remember
thinking that what makes the Haunted
Mansion right cool is it's like that
weird gray zone between it's a little
cartoony ol goofy and also legitimately
scary the way down really well um you
know and I just remember watching them
like there's nothing even remotely
spooky like Ghostbusters is a way
scarier movie the Damned and this and
that's still cartoony the brilliance the
brilliance of the ride is that it's half
the haunting hat scooby-doo and now
somehow mesh perfectly yeah that's my
favorite ride I did honestly but I'm not
I'm not making this up I remember the
two scooby-doo movies better than
something that at least they got the
cartoony stupid part of it right to such
a degree that I remember let's at least
go over what we do remember obviously
our Eddie Murphy's head I remember uh
General Zod as the bomber and this weird
way you talk you have every mile of that
I think I know you made fun of that
senator was in the news and just more
like okay something I remember and I
know y'all better in that day honey hazy
yeah I don't know if there's meant to be
funny but crank me up oh I love that
that's my that's the best part of it
yeah I know you made fun of it a lot but
I genuine God it made us laugh we made
this on a Tim Curry a lot yes Tim Curry
for me is like a good luck charm in the
film's we review because no matter how
bad a film is Tim Curry doing whatever
batshit crazy thing he's going to do
that day is amazing it's always better
day we may make fun of it cuz like well
this is cheesy and over-the-top but
thank God it's cheesy and over-the-top
because it made the movie more
entertained that kind of are we having
any about kind of a problem with the new
in film is that Tim Curry is a
legitimately good clown he's really
funny you know and this was like no he's
just gonna be scary like nobody should
be funny you do I don't know maybe
I don't know the new clone doesn't even
seem that scary to me yeah I mean what
we'll see what we get for an evil yeah
Darius but I remember it's jennifer
Tilly who I really like I think that's a
very funny actress being really miss
cast as the the person in the ball which
is like you know I mean it's like why
put her there Madame Leota I mean you
you want an actress with gravitas yeah
wasn't like a woman that did mulatto
soon yeah arrived in Allentown I love
Jabra chilly but it's like nobody in the
same boat I can't even believe we're
saying words like we want an actress
with gravitas for inside the ball
mansion that is not that character
returning you really think it matters
Eddie oh no not for the entropy in them
yeah yeah the it was the voice of
Maleficent and ever edge I miss also
lady tremaine enough yeah yeah yeah yeah
boy she's got the voice that is ice yeah
I mean July commanding voice there's
been the way they animate her always
she's got that stare like they're gonna
burn you with the heat of your her eyes
there's literally a scene in the movie
where Eddie Murphy starts getting angry
at Liotta and she says look I don't make
the rules okay I just work here
you ya know I mean that's not we
notice she does not winter everybody on
the set of the film yeah exactly
we're out there it's going to be garbage
whatever you know and the funny thing is
like with okay with pirates you know
that has little to do with the right
everyone's la they sneak in a little
something from the attractor like
another Disney movie or something but it
clearly they're like okay we want just
can do our own thing but like it's our
own thing and we like it and we love it
and we really want to have fun with it
this just from the first second you hear
Eddie Murphy and hard dimensions like
know they're doing this to make money
dollars yes yeah and they do not really
want to be like hey let's really make
something that's either uniquely ours or
really the London man's we've been
talking a lot and something that'll get
us some money and has a few aspects of
the ride in and we've been talking about
this a lot
really about how trail is really
misleading it's like a lot of times the
worst trailers the films of X been
pretty good a lot of times streamers
that look good they've been really awful
this was one where I was like no that
was a pitch-perfect trailer that was
exactly what I'm acting I mean really
awful but I'm like yep trailer you you
tell them exactly what I'm not gonna get
all false advertising all fogs advertise
it looked bad and it was bad and any
mercial bidder there yeah he's
technically in it well you know I
remember like like I said you sir go
through it's like oh well they did that
from the right there's one section where
they're just traveling outside they just
see all these goats like in the woods
that's like okay well here's here's just
oh you remember that you remember that
remember that okay that's done and none
of it affects applause yeah none of it
at all and in fact a lot of it was
apparently shoehorned in and reshoots
like the whole scene where he's in the
hallway and he sees like the bulging
door that was all reshoot because test
audiences wanted more fanservice to the
ride yeah what and who was the weird
thing is I wouldn't disagree with that
because that would be about the only
reason you're seeing this if it looks
this bad yeah yeah I mean I'm like at
least you should get that out of it yeah
I mean and and the thing about like
eisenerz rationale for some of these
things was just so ridiculous like he
wanted to adapt all these attractions
but he specifically made notes I don't
want too many references to the actual
attraction because I want people against
his rationale was I want people to be
able to enjoy these movies even if they
haven't ridden it but it's like just
just it doesn't happen just be a
reference yes as you can meld it in as a
thing it's like I thought the Pirates
were we did that by the pirate movie did
that brilliantly especially the scene
where they're in the jail anything
you've been doing that forever that dog
is never going to move now if you're
familiar with the ride that's hilarious
if you're not I'm not a good Rock it's
still one minute straight when he tries
it later when yeah that's a good really
need to give him written the ride yeah
here it's just and and what was Sean is
the one who says well of course there's
always my way and it's like you do that
way sure well right thank you
I also do well yeah um but the yeah the
thing about that line and
right is it supposed to be scary like
that that's the line right before you
see the guy hanging yeah doing there
it's supposed to be this frightening
ominous line like the only way out is
you might have to die and become a ghost
in order to escape this room and they
just give that to Wallace shot now I
love Wallace Shawn he has many wonderful
things he is not a B and has never been
scary he's got to be used right that's
what I find about what I like I even use
this I even used this line in my review
of from Toy Story I'm going to fear some
here but I just don't feel it I'm just
coming off of a noise yeah I feel like
that's an actor who like you know he has
this very distinct face and voice and
everything and you have to know how to
use that right because if not yet he's
going to get grading on you really fast
I'll tell you my problem with the movie
is even even more so than country bears
country bears still felt like a movie
strangely not a good one but this movie
when everything back on it I always
always confuse it for Disney Channel
like movie of the week yeah that all I
think it is in my reign I'm like yeah
that that just ran on Disney Channel
right no that got a theatrical release
it like your skin.you I don't know you
want know what he did yeah I mean maybe
you know the sign maybe you do too
there was actually a power of paranoia
channel movie and Guttenberg Crispin
Crandall that felt more like a hit than
the movie yeah yeah it felt like an
actual movie and it's surprising like
kind of taking it so seriously I'm like
to a point where it's kind of weird how
seriously it's taking about words Steve
Guttenberg in it and it's taking itself
via dogs and cats and a lot of it was
shot at the actual tower terrorists
Morda yeah but if I use one of the
things where it's like back at enemies
that already very good I can't say it's
good but it feels like a movie it feels
like hey let's really try to take this
bizarre idea seriously as possible this
one is clearly just again like so what's
it right a haunted mansion movie I agree
yeah that would have been
hilarious if they tried to shoot the
Haunted Mansion movie on the mansion and
said you just see all these machines
yeah
I will say this about the Haunted
Mansion it looks like a real movie like
like the sets I think are just are just
beautiful but it's one of those movies
where you're paying more attention to
the set than you are to the actors and
that's no honestly I thought that said
so it's very flaky to me really you know
they're they're fake they don't look
like a real house but it does look like
a real house in a haunted house moving
now not yet is it at least not me then
it in converged it with with Jack and
Josh Count Chocula in the horror guru
who ICO review the movie with and they
just they're huge horror aficionados
they love the sets it's like
they were they were like I want that
chair I want that candelabra I want to
but I said that's part of my problem
those I felt the entire movie I'm on a
set watch a really good horror movie I
should be Merce in the environment a few
like oh I'm good no here's the thing I
just I don't remember being bad like the
says being bad I remember like okay I've
seen this place in a million other
haunted house movies and you're right it
feels like it said but sometimes that
can be good like I think Sleepy Hollow
that all felt like it said sleeping
honey was home to another table where
she was always at again yeah but it's so
unique and its own thing where I feel
like with this it's like well okay
that's a set of a haunted house movie
I'm like a scooby-doo movie or something
like that even the scooby-doo movies
when you really could have set are so
weird and so over-the-top and like okay
I remember that more where this seems
very like it's not bad yeah can't feel
standard right honestly as much as I
hate the haunting remake I I have way
less of a problem with that on the
haunting remake I'm like alright I feel
like this house is like kind of real and
large and expansive like I was buying it
much easier on a mansion said I'm just
like set it feels kind of like a theme
park right which I guess maybe you could
claim that's what they're going for but
I never felt like no I'm immersed in
this what in that environment honestly
what what kept me from getting immersed
in it was just the Eddie Murphy was
there like Eddie Murphy's Eddie Murphy's
range only extends as far as whatever
makeup he's got on like a fat guy suit
he'll play a different character as a
bank
nobody plays an authentic Chinese dragon
like it but if he's just Eddie Murphy if
he's nothing if he's not wearing a fat
suit if he's not wearing old man makeup
or something
he's just Eddie Murphy in every
movie I'm even Beverly Hills Cop which I
love it like it well it's heavy Murphy
on yeah I would say he's not that I was
like I never see Eddie Murphy Hydra
Seattle indifferent yeah they're also
like I don't buy that Axel Foley
wouldn't immediately recognize that the
house was haunted like he I so like
Eddie Murphy has always excelled at
playing the trickster the smart guy
who's always three steps ahead of
everyone else and here he's just
supposed to play this clueless doofus
who doesn't realize there's ghosts in I
mean hey Murphy even had that routine in
his delirious special you know how come
white people don't leave the house when
there's a ghost in the house I guess
that have anybody I don't know what I
use I'm not interested in Eddie Murphy
playing a clueless doofus right like I
fun to me like Eddie Murphy pretending
to be a clueless doofus I think is
interesting yeah no exporting that much
of a quiz doofus I just was watching
over two hours I'm like see this like
Eddie Murphy's good at playing you know
the the trickster the huckster the guy
is like one step ahead but maybe is
pretending to be stupid but I'm like to
play this dumb I just didn't think he
did it well because I'm what England I'd
like it was written for Kim Alan it and
they don't yeah Aaron and I can really
see that actually yeah uh ya know that
that's a and you're right that seems to
be the role he's like sort of it
shoehorned into now yeah I just the
stupid I'm just a magic a bunch of
ghosts Carrington alum and him going oh
yeah III called at one point in my
review I called the movie daddy day
scare sis yeah okay yeah yeah I'm typing
anything
yeah like okay I'll say this too um of
all the movie if you were to give me
like all these sort of like ride but
it's like okay which of these rides or
attractions do you think will they do it
as movies on it may not be on mmm
well that's a ready-made or no and for
years they've been talking about the
dude that did like a local tour yeah is
doing her version of this and he will do
when I will put it off and if I dream of
doing this actually I think of even
goofy movies like Darby O'Gill and the
little people the ending that end movie
took a terrifying with a giant banjos
with long fingers yeah they have this
long history and we all Joanie has died
and watcher in the woods they have this
history of doing creepy hell even anyway
really well even like The Nightmare
Before Christmas which is a little more
goofy but still have that nice
atmosphere to exhume you didn't remarry
get and and they excel at like the the
kids movie gateway to gothic horror yeah
like the Haunted Mansion ride and then I
been in their real house it I was in
their wheeled up then easily hell I'll
even point to though they had to get
pg-13 for it uh pirates
you know the pirate movie certainly had
dark grisly edge to it and everything
that was the secret is if you had given
me these three options I would not have
thought oh let's take pirates into a
horror movie realm right like skeletons
and stuff because there was a very small
part of the writer that wasn't just in
the beginning where this is the game and
yeah it's big yeah that's the skeleton
um and and and even that you can kind of
chalk up to well that guy's just dead
yeah and the horror movie aspect took
over most of the film I'm not saying
it's a bad thing but it's I would have
just gone just pirates and so I'm just
like how funny mansion would have been
it but no I feel like they and not again
not necessarily a bad thing but again
they saw the poster for pirates first
before they wrote them because it's like
all of the big that well the skeleton
with the wheel sure right a movie around
that night people are very good at that
so people can write a whole movie around
it be like what movie would I want to
see that had that poster I think I some
to start a tighter than that they said
they a lot of times when they grow an
episode or movie they would think of the
poster first and then write the movie or
a B and I don't always think that's a
bad idea if you're good at it you know
never get the feeling that so nemesis
work you know thing that the Haunted
Mansion is there's a common
misconception that it was made because
pirates was such a big hit but it only
came out like five months after the
Pirates I remember seeing a trailer for
the Haunted Mansion movie when I went to
see pirates so it was Greenlee
well before then um but you know it does
kind of feel like a pre-emptive apology
like we're sorry this was good it really
was a case if they just threw a bunch of
against the long see what would
stick it is do it no more kids do we do
more adult to do more action and it just
and none of it really works I mean and
the Pirates words
well pirates work well and aliens didn't
like ya mansion but though we're sitting
here now having eye I saw pirates five
earlier this summer and dear God work oh
yeah done that navigate go to the wrong
wanted man yeah yeah it's like next
Disney please are there and they're
trying to build a whole they're trying
to do even more it's like just let it
die for God's sake yeah III think I
think with Lindsay Alice said on Twitter
like you know she was watching the first
Pirates movies like it's so quaint to
see just a sword fight in one of these
movies where they're not like riding
dinosaurs or secession well I actually
started in the second one yeah but it
still was kind of cute and fun and
inventive like running in the wheel but
I I lost it at the the third movie is
where I'm like this is bottom of the
barrel awful well I have not looked
about I started to have reservations at
the Davy Jones squid man thing it's like
that that was what he goes to be
frightening and it just looks silly cuz
he films get really really complicated
and the first film if you look at are
the Pirates again get a little off track
but the first on Pirates you know is it
is super complicated go over the places
but it's a simple idea these pirates are
cursed they want to get rid of errors
and they need so either Jack Sparrow or
someone which a granting it we've got
drunk on it yo no no your to ask me
what is the plot of the second third
fourth and fifth I'm like oh Christ
going around something about a Davy
Jones a super important about saving
pyrogen everywhere yeah I'll savor that
Pyrus universe or whatever it game
really gets drunk on it so it's like
this is important this means something
no you're a silly pirate movie
and don't you ever forget it no
wrong we need to hang a little boy at
the opening of yeah
we need to go to Sam hard last year oh
yeah no yeah we gotta this means
something shut up we got a shot on
Pirates of the Caribbean we got a save
piracy at our proud history of human
traffic sound like people defend all
right what do you write that sounds
where do we have to save piracy like
actually really we her how can you
imagine if army of Darkness like was
more like Braveheart or
something where it's like this super
serious movie like completely drunk and
full of itself and as I know that's a
pyrex equal this was just stupid it was
always many stupid uh you know and then
you have something like on dementia or
you would feel like this could be kind
of a big gothic in some aspect even kind
of deep story but it's like no it's just
this goes the goofball Eddie Murphy
y-you know and it's just like you know
no you need something really graphic and
cool about this um yeah I kinda like my
ghost dad as a Disney Channel movie my
god yeah and they and they both you know
had famous black act blame is famous
black comedians in the in the dad role
of the yeah and not a family only thing
we can say about the Santa Claus liar
liar yeah exactly but B um and C I think
we will say you know the crazy thing
about Haunted Mansion is the ending of
it specifically kind of precluded any
sequels or cuz they didn't die did
singing that's all it ended with the
curse being broken on all the ghosts
ascending to heaven like a pure
flix movie yeah yeah like right at that
ending the ending of the Haunted Mansion
pissed me off as much as the ending of
the haunting remake to you guys on time
pretty much the same thing pretty much
because because it's like okay the
Haunted Mansion is probably the most
beloved ride that Disney has ever made
just in terms of people just sheerly
loving it I mean people are cosplay as
characters from it we're only seeing
like one Olav for the camera racism of
Splash Mountain Man
I'm not kidding there is a documentary
now called foolish mortals being
crowdfunded just a documentary up
Haunted Mansion fans like like uncle I
love the hot imagine yeah right people
have what taken the ashes of their loved
ones to the ride and like oh my god oh
there to think about it well I walked
out with my body then they always vacuum
it up they always have to shut down the
ride when I was in the town but so
grandpa's in a landfill somewhere in
Burbank
great we're that is your nightmare what
where where you going
wait what a silver car Danice don't use
a ghost oh okay
they're putting they're putting Donny in
the ride
all right all right so we just hurry on
that over there um ya know the last
thing I feel like I can say about is
that yeah is I can never say his name is
El Toro Jesuit el carro was going to do
this Haunted Mansion move and he pulled
out when he's pulled out a lot of
projects he always kind of teases in
many ways I'm thinking like this happens
a lot with him yeah no but he did a
movie Oh was it was it Crimson crown
prison peak yeah yeah yeah which
honestly was like yeah hey well this is
the Haunted Mansion movie I know he got
tired of working with Disney so it's
like screw it I'll just make my own
yeah a Gore cooker the blackjack yeah I
mean gorgeous movie hard to say if it's
good but it's interesting uh but it's
one of those things were it like again I
could have you like on a bench no I
guess there can be a good Haunted
Mansion movie and I feel like it was
kind of haunting it was made in 1863 i
watch I feel like enough time has passed
where it's like they can do this now I
couldn't even see this almost as like a
Disney animated movie because there we
look at a cartoony but you get kind of
like the Pixar stories and people on it
what I love to see is that it focuses on
the goats and like the different people
that come to maybe try and live in the
house and the ones they scare away stuff
but it's just about the ghosts haunting
you because it's always like the people
in Cal's dreams I go why can't we just
get to know the go in movie we're like
the ghosts haunt the house is about the
ghost uh so Beetlejuice pretty much yeah
anyway Otis and it's the symptom is the
totally that is honestly the tone of the
end of the ride is kind of similar to
Beetlejuice in
the music even kind of sense yeah you
know why not why not have something work
in grabbing his balls at the end of the
ride was working with our right
well I mean why not have like okay even
appeal jizz you mainly got the two you
got a couple yeah they go to another
world they see some are ghosts but they
come back it's mainly the two and then
beetlejuice I mean I want to made you
have all these goats living in this
place like this giant community how
would that work how would they work off
each other what different character them
even over the years and years that
they've been there at seeing times
change and stuff it's like how happening
would that be just see like the years
passed in this house and with these
barriers go Doug how does this help any
movie movie care so little about the
ghosts that it just sends them all to
heaven at the end we see a cut like
maybe four ghosts and and and one of
them is you got Terence Stamp Nathaniel
Parker Wallace Sean and Wallace Shawn's
wifey I can't remember the actress's
name and they all turn a surprise you
remember that much for is okay for down
995 to go where's the rest of them and
they care so little days it's like like
I said this is one of the most beloved
rides ever did you really think any of
the fans who were going to see this
movie anyway wanted to see an unwanted
mansion as a happy ending yeah it's just
ridiculous it's the best you could do is
like an ambiguous yeah yeah yeah and he
doesn't do ambiguous endings very well
every game yeah I just kinda have to
have a happy ending but yeah or even
like I don't know I don't know I could
have exactly yeah like a happy and sad
thing I mean it's mostly happy but by
the standards of the original book it
was half full we a happy ending are you
me doesn't get Esmeralda so oh
no that's bittersweet not really you get
Jennifer Love Hewitt and the sequel yeah
that didn't happen you know that didn't
happen
yeah he gets kids respecting him as the
not monster and the man because Frollo
was the monster who is the monster
tomorrow now I guess yeah
now that was those Odyssey dollars very
happy lovely okay especially compared to
the original story yeah yeah um I'm
still waiting for the Broadway version
of a security system with all these
live-action reaming I would love to be
the Broadway line because I don't think
having that you get out that you mean
learning from was that you're the one
from the critic if you see a hunch bad
no no no no like the actual Disney
Broadway line I don't know no I don't
think having them get out of the house
and learning some Disney side moral
lesson and being happy and then having
the goats still hanging out there in the
haunted mansion waiting for somebody
else is a sad ending I think that's
perfectly ambiguous that you could have
had it yeah oh yeah so I think they
thought the idea that they're cursed to
be there that they're the whole point of
the ride was that the 999 happy haunts
are happy they're in their element
they enjoy being ghosts they're free if
I got bitching about things and it's
like and it's we the living who have a
problem where I mean I mean your lover
did when the who's the one guy on the
ride who's uncomfortable it's the it's
the living guys the animatronic of the
groundskeeper who by the way this shows
how wrongheaded eisenerz let's
not have too much fanservice in this in
this movie apparently in earlier drafts
that character was a character in the
movie and he was going to be played by
[Laughter]
Marvin yeah oh yeah oh you get up mr.
jacket hoodie it kind of looks like
Donna yeah and now that'll never happen
cuz he's dead no no they just cg is
happening for real I'm hanging on that
haunted mansion right now
no no now and the but yeah that's a good
point like all the ghosts in the ride
are happy they're content they're having
fun and diverse to be there they know
how I want to repeat on the visa living
wasn't valise a living are the ones who
have a problem with it even the song is
they're coming out to socialize they're
going out all creepy and gooey di hai
whatever that little bit like done us it
had a resurgence right around them to
know that would be awesome yeah it would
have been the only thing you'd remember
about the movie what I would love
everyone's just about that guy going in
yeah yeah yeah hot it out some stuff so
yeah look no you got some III will just
say this I like do you did you ever
think that we'd be sitting here looking
back talking about how awful this movie
is with Disney in the position that
they're in now it because I I mean like
okay this is the weird thing about
Disney is we ripped through to Disney
Renaissance ha's right we went through
most of the 80s when Disney was in the
like I mean and then we starting
with I'd say around Little Mermaid
through and then Beauty and the Beast
like afternoon of those yeah Disney
Afternoon Disney like kicked it back up
again awesome they were on top of the
world and then we lived through that
second downfall the later right here's
the direct-to-video sequels the movie
sucking the closing down of the 2d
animations right I mean really it's just
in the past four years old someone's
like Oh Disney's doing solid like the
heavy like to re battle captain we have
but everything el while Pixar was out of
it and they were doing their own thing
and then they started the Disney Channel
movies again big and then they're making
the regular movies good again and now
you got on Star Wars Disney owns Marvel
Disney have owned some they've got
frickin Moana frozen all my vehicles
they might have their own Netflix now
why we're recording is they're pulling
out Netflix to have their own street
maybe it's really weird it's we've seen
their own costume universe yeah Disney
crashes and to Disney like bounce bags
oh we were since we were born unser
there's been more to in the past and
there will
be more in the yeah exactly weird thing
when when this movie can when the
Haunted Mansion came out because we were
saying yeah it's right before pirates
right it was right at right right after
pirates
okay very shortly I still would have I
still remember thinking that pirates was
like a lucky break yeah I got look I
wasn't really willing to believe that oh
honey I almost shut it down eyes are
neither almost shut it down anyone a
Jack Sparrow to be played by Matthew
McConaughey hmm I'm not talking I saw up
with irn begin out between this and
country bears like I just thought this
means done is he's done like this is
like they're going to be in a really
crappy position probably for another 10
15 maybe 20 years and you know or maybe
they'll get bought by Sevilla otherwise
Omer and here we a few years later
talking about it like and business I'm
literally Disney just dislike Disney WB
so me impairment was like four companies
on every Gus you guys have seen waking
Sleeping Beauty right I documented about
Disney from the mid 80s mid 90s and
there you could make it into Massa dated
yeah it really is we don't ask me that
but you could you can make an amazing
trilogy like you can do the dark Empire
Strikes Back version about from the mid
90s to the mid 2000s where they went
from Lion King to home on the rain and
then the comeback third movie where they
went from home on the range to
frozen and Roseanne Barr is a can I make
this year like I feel like like you said
there with Mary I'll quit staring there
III feel right there's got to be more of
these as well and it's but it's always
so interesting interesting seeing how
they come back what they do what they
change and what they keep the same what
they pick up from like the old days and
what they adapt if you feel like the
bottom the bottom is gonna fall out
eventually here but how long it'll take
I mean this could be a few years ago
could be 10 or 20 when how many they own
and how well they're doing yeah I feel
like this might really take a while
before they know that much like Krispy
Kreme they have over saturated the
market a little bit and I'm like I'm
worried there may be a little bit
between Marvel and Star Wars and then
their normal stuff I'm like kind of
maybe there's going to be burnout at
some point but I don't know like I'm not
at the point
oh I hate everything but marriages yet
no they're so clever
they're so quite when they do marvel
when they do Star Wars they don't want
the Disney logo in there they want to
keep that as they do own it but they
want to keep the Disney name off of it
which is so clever
it's a nut busy never did it will begin
with maybe touchstone and yeah and I
guess you can say mere Maxwell mathema
diversified their portfolio announced
now that one of those can tank and they
still like they've got three they've got
three options that will four because I
think the only ESPN
yeah yeah so they've got like they don't
know things down any one of those could
fall oh got me more than this or they've
got like ABC yeah yeah I can see like
ABC ESPN in the same like more
challenging kind of but I'm just saying
they've got these kind of like they've
got a number of options like in their
portfolio looks like stock talk
now yeah I had one of these can fall now
and they're still gonna be doing all
right where I feel like earlier what it
was Disney they did then what an option
it's just like they were you know
banking on the Black Cauldron yeah they
had a film anybody Care Bears behind out
and the Disney Channel which was mostly
which was pretty new in the eighties and
that was it so I was like if you had one
of those Falls good yeah like that was
it yeah so there's an idea like they can
experiment a little bit more now too and
they also like to kind of have the
formula but they have also enough wiggle
room as I let's do some a little
different in this formula as well like
the Marvel film we're definitely giving
a more month goodbye there sure but
there's that wiggle room of like let's
have fun let's try this like a week we
have we have space to fail I mean
doesn't work but I mean if any franchise
has been yet you would expect to be
oversaturated and just formulaic and
dull by now it would be the Marvel
movies just because there's been so
goddamn many of them but have you seen
the trailers for Ragnarok yeah amazing I
I'm waiting a yeah wait for the bottom
for me victory yeah for me but Jerry's a
little out like I say that I feel like
I'm getting to a point where I'm like
man's getting like it's starting to wear
me down but I'm like 'nygh nygh looks
pretty awesome black Hampton what I'm
like and I can't wait for the in the
Infinity yeah so I I don't know I'm like
I say that but at the same time I'm like
yeah I'm gonna Street and I'm actually
really psyched so it's like it hasn't
happened yet but yeah I don't know I I
feel like at some point but that's the
thing even if Marvel if Marvel tanks
like the bottom falls out of that it's
like they've got everything else now
we're in the old days it's like even as
a movie studio
they were so limited to family-friendly
stuff right whereas like a big studio
like WB or something does everything so
I don't know I I'm just I'm good quote
the fugitive and just say that company's
a monster they got there anyway Haunted
Mansion yeah whatever yeah we should we
should prior rampart also whoa I'll
leave you with this and it's kind of a
perfect distillation of just how
boneheaded everything on the movie is
the actress who plays Eddie Murphy's
wife Marcia Thomason really good actress
actually does not do a good performance
in the movie but there's a reason for it
and it's not her fault
she's British and Apollo that explains
the right man now that he's British
research dumb no man she's British and
the producers apparently catch her
before bothering to ask if she could do
an American accent Oh shoes and she's
doing her best at an American accent
but it doesn't sound that great and it
just sounds like she can't deliver dr.
Brennan I did whatever I had I it battle
bit she's British
it's her ethnic and yeah there's no good
British actor no bye no you say she
harder to overlook um I honestly don't
remember I don't remember having a
person with really but uh yeah II she
was gonna ask me once you say in the
movie I am bill is rebel and most of the
time yeah I kind of remember that yeah
and oh yeah you could have just had her
keeper accent and he just married some
why is that so hard to do it's like no
you can't have somebody marrying a
foreigner like it'll just destroy it
like it but that way they can keep their
own ends like it's not difficult and
there happens a lot to actually yeah I'm
three and daughter yeah I would say like
there's uh you know we've seen this a
lot before British right
the American American trying to be
British and stuff like that it's like
sometimes it works what something for
the Rings I get it that has a British
BAM yells any better British and stuff
like that but yeah if it's like just a
movie where it's like yeah very
depressed persons like that let's
totally believe it looks nothing like up
Kampai and it's like no I think that
makes total sense I think the audience
would want some acknowledgement of it or
something and they didn't I don't know I
don't know but it's it's stupid
yeah but yeah I'm the critical thing it
like the director of it Rob Minkoff
author Lion King dude yeah yeah he
co-director in Lion King and sand the
Stuart little movies and those of the
doer little and the dreamworks peabody &
sherman movie more recently yes yes good
stuff and and I've heard him in
interviews and stuff he seems like a
really smart funny guy I don't know what
when I don't know how he let this movie
get I guess Eddie Murphy just you know
soon as Eddie Merck because the thing is
Eddie Murphy was even in back then when
he was just off a Pluto Nash you know
maybe that's why they got like they
could get him at a cheap price just
bombed all right so you're handed the
script yeah and it's this script you're
handed Eddie Murphy and these and the
British actress who has to take the
American accent yep yep yep ethnically
she's British so she's already working
behind the eight-ball
uh but your hand is all of this you've
got eyes they're breathing down your
back you know what the hell are you
going to do like it's like I am
sometimes yeah I mean it's not as
directors writers like sometimes you
just handed the job they're like okay
this is a paycheck there's nothing I can
really do to save this so I'm going to
do my job show up get it on celluloid or
digital now I guess and just and that's
it will push it out and you know if it
sinks or fails it's like probably not
going to be on me it will just be
considered like eisenerz folly or
Disney's or and I'll just hopefully go
on to do something better yes that one
it says sometimes it's just you do it
you can that's just like nope I can't
save this directors can save a movie
some can tank it and some just do their
job and I just feel like he just did his
job yeah like I can't say if the world's
was off we directed film I'm like oh
that's a visual I I mean honestly the
fact
you don't even remember that much about
it like it just shows it's honestly less
a god-awful movie than just a thoroughly
forgettable mediocre way yeah and and
for a ride as awesome as the Haunted
Mansion that might be the biggest insult
of all and as I always say honestly to
is to a certain degree Garbage Pail Kids
a Garbage Pail Kids and Momma me in a
couple there's a couple words like it
doesn't apply that because they're so
awful I'd really still hate them but to
me it's much much more worse to be that
kind of movie that's come on we forget
oh yeah we do
Elsie's much as I hate Garbage Pail Kids
the Mamma Mia if we - made me have an
emotion rages and I remember it yeah a
fiasco is way better than a failure yeah
it's just it because it's so much more
fascinating hmm
especially a boring yeah so yeah there
it is not not a good woman yes they were
pursuing that said I'm gonna have
nothing to talk about who we talked to
fair about but I was just trying to not
talk about the haunted man yes a man we
did talk about like Disney is about like
that but yes that's that's our general
thoughts not summers but simply not good
and it just kind of don't forgettable
get a rebound out there a glass you're
good now feel me you can do it you can
do it yes let's go and do another
unoriginal project don't have an
original it's fairly hot in that I'm
okay with that's the one that when you
can do that
you're the haunted me yeah and I'm doubt
that you don't give him to be your dad
and they were looking on you're gonna do
a kajillion remount and when boiling
destroys can be better attraction ride
reboot 1-yard they're on they're making
a Jungle Cruise movie starring the rock
now yeah called Jumanji yeah video game
Boogaloo yeah alright go ahead
I've enjoyed every Brambleberry awesome
I'm just one more okay go on go on
I got nothing okay okay youtube.com
slash Tony gold marks just fell out I
know cut that out
cut that out I shut this off shut this
whole alright shut up I'll shut this
whole up hola
you